so today's talk uh pointers in my python
it's more likely than you think we're
going to be talking about three things
uh the first of which if my slides will
increment for me
wouldn't be a conference without
technical issues there we go the first
of which is what pointers are and where
you'll see them in your python the
second is what the id of a python object
is and why it matters and lastly we'll
be looking at how c python can tell when
you're done using an object in memory
and what it does next so let's kick off
with uh what is a pointer
a pointer is a code object that
basically references another it points
to another object
so for example if you have an object in
your python a namespace its name is a
pointer to that object um and it's a
concept that comes up a lot in c
programming so here we've got what
pointers look like in some c code you
don't really need to care about this um
and in c
it when you declare a pointer it
actually matters what the type of object
that it points to is so void is agnostic
you can have something that points to an
integer or something that points to a
character um but this is python and it's
duct type so you don't need to know
about any of that
um when it comes to writing python code
where you'll see this come up really
often is in pointer aliasing this is
something that trips people up a lot
when they're new to python which is also
known as that phenomenon where something
changes but you aren't sure how like you
you've changed a variable without
realizing that you did it um so we'll
see an example here um i've got a list
and i've called it a
and yeah i've just set that up in the
namespace there
and what we're going to do is we're
going to set b is equal to a and then
we're going to edit that list by
accessing it through the name of b so
cool we've got a list b and we're
changing what the second word of the
list says and we're changing it from
cool to awesome
but you can see that we've also changed
our list a
by having changed b because a and b were
both pointers to the same code object
even though they're two different names
for the same thing
uh and if we don't want this to happen
we want to have a version of a that we
can edit without editing the original uh
we can use the copy method so instead of
just setting it equal to a we can set it
equal to a copy and what this does is it
creates a new list object and then
copies all the contents of that over so
if we want to change the second word of
our list c from awesome to amazing um we
can have that and we can see that it
hasn't actually changed the value of the
list a
this is all well and good but when we
create a copy of something and we copy
all of its contents over so all of those
strings got copied over um what if they
had been lists that had been copied over
so what if our pointers
so our point to a to a list
what if there were pointers inside that
list
so here we have a different list it's a
list of lists
and
what we're going to do now is see how
copy is not always sufficient
so i've got
this list of lists i've made a copy of
it and i'm accessing the first element
of it which is itself a list and i'm
appending a new element to it with
append c
and you can see that that has changed
the list that lives within a as well
even though we did a copy we're still
changing the contents of a because
the element the elements of the list
that got copied over when we did that
copy method
are themselves objects that are pointed
to
um
and we can get around this even if it's
pointers all the way down with the deep
copy method um
and what we're doing here is we're
instead of we've got our list of lists a
and instead of just using copy we're
going to use deep copy and now what that
does is it not only creates a new list
object but for every element inside that
list it's actually creating and copying
that um whole whole cloth it's not
actually just sort of pointing at the
same objects that are in a it's creating
new versions of them with the same
values
and so now if we want to have see what
happens if we try and change some of the
elements of our new list
we can see it's been changed in the new
list that we've made c
but actually if we go back and look at
our original list a we can see that we
haven't changed the contents of that
so deep copy is for when you actually
want to create
an actual copy that is not pointing to
the same objects in memory but new
objects with the same values um so that
you don't end up with point aliasing
just to recap
equals makes a new pointer to the same
object so if you've got a list and you
say list a and b is equal to a both b
and a are pointers to the same object
copy will make a new list object but any
pointers that were contained within the
original code object you'll just get new
pointers to that those objects
and deep copy copies the entire thing or
rather recreates the entire thing and
gives you a completely new object in
memory you wouldn't always want to do
this even though it protects you from
pointer aliasing and changing things
when you don't intend to because it's
more memory intensive
so depending on what you actually need
your code to do you might choose one of
these three methods
right i promised some tuples behaving
badly in the abstract and the idea of
pointers and mutating things in place is
obviously you know mutating things
really closely related to mutability of
objects so
tuples are immutable once you've created
a tuple all of its elements have to be
the same for the lifetime of that tuple
but those elements can be pointers so
let's say that the first element of our
tuple is a pointer
what if we change what the value of that
that it points to is so let's say that
we've got a tuple that contains lists
now the first element of this tuple is a
list one two three and we can append to
it
um
the value of the first element of that
tuple hasn't changed it's the pointing
to the same object in memory but that
object in memory has been mutated
um we can but one thing we can we can uh
mutate it directly but what if we want
to do something really similar and do
the use the plus equals operation which
is modifying something in place it'll
throw us an error because we're trying
to assign to the value of a tuple an
element of the tuple we're trying to set
a1 equal to something which you can't do
in a tuple
and we expect this right we expect it to
throw us an error you can't assign to
objects within a tuple
um but
if we then print out the value of the
second
element of our tuple we'll see that that
zed that we tried to add to it is in
fact there
and this is because
when you do plus equals the plus mutates
the object in place and then tries to do
an assignment
and it gets it gets through the first
part as we saw before you can append to
a list in a tuple even though the tuple
itself is immutable you can't then
assign to it so it gets through part of
it successfully adding the z to that
list but then it fails uh it gives us an
error at the assignment part of it um so
a bit of unexpected behavior uh when
you're trying to mix mutable and
immutable types in this specific
situation
um
all right
i'm going to move on to object ids
and when we're thinking about b and a
and they're both pointing to the same
object like how can you tell when two
objects are the same well every object
in python has an id and you can get it
by calling the id built in on that
object
um an id is unique no two objects can
have the same id if they are not well no
two different objects can have the same
id if two objects have the same id
they're the same object
it is constant the id of a given object
will not change over the lifetime of
that object
and most python implementations use the
object's address in memory as its id so
that's what c python does but not all of
them so for example sculpt which is a
python to javascript compiler actually
just generates and then caches a random
number for every given object when the
id is queried for it uh and this is
going to be true of any uh java
javascript based
python implementations because of the
way that the jvm works
so we're going to focus on c python
essentially all these examples i'm about
to show you are from c python because
it's the most common distribution um
we've got a list again and we've called
its id built in on it and it's given us
a number
if we set b equal to a and we check the
ids of those objects you can see that
they are the same number they're two
pointers to the same object that has the
same address in memory so they've got
same pointers uh they've got the same id
now if we make a copy of a it's creating
a new list object in memory and then
copying all the contents over so when we
call id on them we can see that it is
different these two objects are
genuinely different
whereas b and a were the same they were
just two names for the same thing
so
one some of the ways we can tell whether
two objects are generally the same is
with these two oh sorry let me go back
um
my goodness
uh sorry
um
let's set up this situation again where
we've got a is a list and
hang on
a is a list b is equal to a or set b
equals a so we've just made another
pointer to that list and c is a copy of
a called um used created by calling the
copy method
um
all right
what happens if we use some of the
python's ways of evaluating whether
these two things the same
a is equal to b
true
a is b it's also true but when we look
at c we can see that the double equals
operator gives us true but is gives us
false a is equal to c
but it's not c
so why does this happen
so the is comparator uses the id of
objects in order to determine its truth
value
so a is b is exactly equivalent to
saying that their ids are the same
whereas the double equals operator
uses the double underscore equals method
so what is that
um we're quite familiar with double
underscore methods i think in python you
might have seen our double underscore
string double underscore rapper or
double underscore in it it's obviously a
really common one and these are also
called magic methods or dunder methods
for as assortment of double underscore
and
double underscore equal method defines
the behavior of the double equals
operator when it's applied to instances
of this of the class that the double e
underscore method is defined upon
um so we can see an example of this
here i've got a user-defined class and
i've defined an equals method on it this
takes the value of self so the object
that's in question and whatever it's
being compared to which here i've called
other
and all i'm doing in this method is
returning self is other which as we just
saw is equivalent to saying that their
ids are the same this is actually the
default behavior for any user defined
class in python by default two instances
of it will only compare equal
if they have the same id
what we're going to do now is look at a
class that's got i've given a name just
for the clarity of the examples that i'm
about to show you and i've defined its
equals method to always return true no
matter what
and when you're overriding dunder
methods you have to be pretty careful
because sometimes it can result in some
unique behavior or a sort of confusing
behavior so we're going to see an
instance of that
i've got two instances of this class
that i just
defined
one is called a and one is called b so
they have different names
but they still compare true as class
instances because i overrode that equals
method to return true no matter what any
two instances of this class will return
this will return as being equals
um
which is you might not expect that
they've got different names
but we've told the equals operator that
they they're the same thing always
return true we can of course do the
opposite always return false and here we
have a unique class that will never
compare equal to another member of this
class another instance of this class
uh not even itself
so we've instantiated my unique class
and said is a equals to a well we're
using the double equals double
underscore equals operator and as we
just saw
that always returns false
even if the instances are actually the
same object
so you can see we can get some really
funky behavior going on that
um we've got object lifetimes as well so
we said that the um id of an object
exists and is constant and unique for
the lifetime of that object and what
that means is as long as that object
exists in memory so how do objects
stop existing in memory
well one way is
well what happens when an object is
about to be removed from mre is that its
double underscore dell method is called
so that's another one of these dunder
methods magic methods
and
what the dell method does is it's also
called a finalizer it's just what's
called when the object is about to see
python well python is about to remove
the object from its working memory
um
so we're going to look at this example
throughout the the next section we're
going to use this example and it's a
really simple class it just has a name
as before for the clarity of examples
and when an object's about to be removed
from memory it just gives us a print
statement to say that it's doing it
so
python frees memory in one of two ways
either by keeping track of how many
references to that memory there is and
freeing the memory when that number
reaches zero
or by garbage collection because
reference counting isn't always
sufficient and we're going to see why in
a minute
um so let's start off with reference
counting
we have an instance of this class that i
just defined earlier my dell class
called dave and then we delete him and
you can see that when the reference to
dave the only reference that there is
is deleted
the object is also deleted as you can
see by the print statement that we put
in being called
now that isn't the only way that you can
create a reference to a thing by just
instantiating and assign it to a
variable name we can also create
multiple references or pointers to the
same object in memory here we've got
alice and we give alice another name
another variable another pointer called
also alice and then when we
write del alice
she's not deleted because there's still
a living reference to alice also alice
but if we delete that finally she is
deleted
so if there are references still around
in your namespace to an object it will
not be deleted by reference counting
what happens if you have two objects
that refer to each other but don't have
any other references in the namespace
that's called a cyclic reference
and it's what can happen sometimes when
there will still be references to
objects if you've got this sort of
situation where um you've got two
objects and each one refers to the other
those references will be known to the
reference counter the their reference
counter can never hit zero even if those
two objects are not actually reachable
from the python namespace that you still
have
and this is where garbage collection can
come in so we're going to see an example
without garbage collection of what
happens in this situation so we've got
jane and bob and that arbitrary python
classes objects so we can just set
attributes on them they're friends bob
has a reference to jane and jane has a
reference to bob
when we delete them
uh we've now removed any way of
accessing these two objects from our
namespace we no longer have a pointer to
jane and appointed to bob that we can
get at by name
um but they point to each other so the
reference counters for each of them will
not be zero they will not be picked up
um by the reference counting mechanism
and deleted and as you can see after
we've hit after i've typed in del jane
and del bob
that dell method on each of them has not
been called we're not seeing that print
statement they're saying deleting jane
and bob
um
so reference counting isn't going to be
sufficient to make sure that our memory
is cleared when it actually needs to be
this is where the garbage collector
comes in and we're going to look
specifically at c python's garbage
collection so
c python's garbage collector works as
follows it detects cyclic isolates which
is a term for that situation that we
just saw when you've got two or more
objects that reference each other in a
cyclic way but they are isolated from
the name space there is no pointer there
is no name in the name space that can
actually access that memory so c
python's garbage collector detects these
it will call the finalizers that's so
that's the double underscore dell method
on each of these
um and so long as those dell underscore
the double underscore dell methods as
long as those finalizers don't do
anything that causes the garbage
collector to abort and there is
something that they can do which we'll
go into in a minute
as long as that doesn't happen it will
go and systematically break all of those
cyclic references so it will it will
stop jane being bob's friend and then
jane can be deleted and so on and so
forth um and so all the ref once it
breaks the right cyclic references the
reference counter goes to zero and then
those objects are deleted
so
we'll go back to well we can have a look
at the garbage collector um all you can
need to do is import gc and the way that
the garbage collector works is it tracks
objects um
so certain objects aren't tracked so for
example strings certain built-in objects
aren't tracked by the garbage collector
they cannot contain pointers and
therefore they can never become part of
a cyclic isolate so you can look at
certain objects and see if they're
tracked by the garbage collector with
this method strings are not tracked but
lists are they contain pointers they can
become part of a cyclic isolate by
default um all instances of user creator
classes are tracked by the garbage
collector because
you can add arbitrary attributes onto
them and so obviously they can become
part of cyclic isolates
so
the garbage collector the way that it
detects these cyclic isolates is it uses
a traversal method to access all the
pointers that an object has access to
so if we've got a list we can call this
get reference method on it and that what
that does is it goes through your object
and says what are all the things that
you point at and this list has a pointer
to the strings list and a
and this is not guaranteed to be in the
order in any particular order i think by
this get reference method
um
and so what this does is it allows the
garbage selector to detect these cyclic
isolates essentially
so let's set up the situation we had
before a cyclic isolate with jane and
bob the smallest one you can have with
only two elements bob and jane are
friends and then we delete them from the
namespace
so now if we import the garbage
collector and when it's collect method
which is essentially giving it a bit of
a kick and say go and do your thing um
you can see that those finalizers are
now called and the number at the end is
the number of objects that have been
deleted from the namespace or deleted
from memory rather so it's four because
you've got jane and then her name jane
and bob and then his name attribute bob
so four objects have been removed from
memory
all right
so
i mentioned earlier that there is a way
that this can not fail but a way that
that garbage collection process can be
aborted and that is if the finalizer
method
does something to create a reference to
the object in question outside of the
cyclic isolate and we'll see an example
of how that what that looks like
so i'm going to define a new bad class
called my bad dell class
and this what this does is in its dell
method it uh it
creates a new global variable called
person and then assigns the object that
is in the process of being deleted
to that person object is creating a new
pointer in the global namespace and
assigning itself to it
um and then it will print the the
statement that we had before
so
again cyclic isola same situation bob
and jane of friends we delete them
and what happens if we call the garbage
collection now
it calls their finalizers by printing
you and you can see that it has by
printing those uh print statements but
then it says zero
nothing's been deleted and this is
because there was a now there is a
pointer outside the cycling isolate it's
not isolated anymore um and what we wear
the way we can see this is if we
reference this new global variable
person we can see it's an instance of
that class um and it's also at this
point i'd like to point out that bob is
the object that had its finalizer called
second because that was the one that was
printed last
um and if we go and look at this
personal object its name is bob
so in the process of deleting bob which
was the second finalizer that was called
it set itself to this global variable
and we can see that jane also still
exists as the friend attribute of this
of this object but if we try and access
jane by the name
small j jane
that name has been deleted from the
namespace um
now we've got into a situation where
these two code objects still exist still
have their name attributes but can't be
accessed by the names of the originally
assigned to them
and they've had their finalizers called
already
so what we can do of course is just
delete the person variable delete that
pointer to the object and now if we run
the garbage collection again
you can see it says that it's deleted
those four objects it did not run their
finalizes again an object can only ever
have its finalizer run once to prevent a
situation like this from being
unresolvable you know because if it ran
that fine laser every every single time
you'd never be able to leak the object
because it would always be creating a
reference to itself within the finalizer
so finalized can only ever be run once
for this exact purpose um and i don't
really recommend doing this in code
unless you know that you have a really
really good reason to for exactly the
reason that it creates this kind of
unintuitive behavior um but that's been
an example of the uh of garbage
collectors and del or finalizers
behaving badly um
and i think that about wraps us up yes
and this has been pointers in my python
a uh was a stop tour of some of python's
memory management um i hope you enjoyed
it and i will be uh available to answer
questions